I look different and it was scandal not  in the full wine I'll correct I'm gonna  wait a little bit while tidge for  January for two comebacks trip were you  tired of like holding purses and coats  and faux no actually I'll be going back  to work in July doing as much as I can  they'll still be bigger bags Prada  luggage as there was last time big coats  don't worry I'll be waddling my way  around OPA don't worry  today pregnant in heels Carrie got the  SAG after foundations actors inspiration  award and we're glad she's back to her I  share everything side now you take a  little break from social media which  ended quickly because backstage hang it  with JLo back for a little window  because I couldn't not share my Vegas  extravaganza literally was thinking  about what I saw we had a blast so I  didn't want to not share that trip with  everybody come on let's face it we're  all addicted I mean like literally right  here dice roll here we go